like to skip peck for like baggage
Silverman's new album and the name of
their latest single the band's been
stirring up the charts for over a decade
guns vlada we noticed that as a band are
focused on the music kept getting fuzzy
and we wanted it back again and as per
so light baggage means a very sharp
focus on the music
kill me
life does capek also implies a relief
from emotional strain Santa Paws frogs
ebuddy tides i'm at my home country over
time you accumulate quite a few
experiences that may not have been all
that Pleasant they can hang over you and
after a while you start brooding so
you're not as quick with your decisions
and sometimes not so happy with one or
the other when for us I think the song
was a conscious decision to get some
things off our chest so the band could
go forward might the game come to their
beds
they landed a hit in 2004 with their
debut album and the single symphony now
pop music with German lyrics was back in
style zilberman was soon filling the
concert halls
Ergen bus blabbed something remains was
silver moons second number one single
their fast rise and lasting success
surprised the musicians more than anyone
they've collected 12 platinum records in
several awards tinha silver moon silver
moons 10 years old and those ten years
felt like being on an express train at
high speed without stopping even once
once and all of a sudden oh we noticed
that it's time to hit the brakes for
just a little while the band members
flew to Nashville to record their latest
tunes they got them all in the can
within 12 days playing together in one
of the famous studios instead of
recording each instrument separately
happen especially when we play live on
stage we keep getting the feeling we
could do a whole lot more something
clicks when we all make music together
that's her and that inspired the idea to
approach this fifth album the same way
basically it's like one of our live
performances something is created that's
more than the sum of the four with their
previous album three years in the past
now they can take the stage with light
baggage
this was our first real break and now
we've got the energy to start again it's
a different kind of energy the
experience we've collected we can start
fresh the motivation is no less than 10
years ago for since birth yarn
Zilber moon is shining again and having
fun making music in spring they'll be
going on a major tour with Lexus capek
you